drivi involved 5x - 1 small dog 5 X - 1
x okay so differentiate that will form
this statement
alright just like here in fact you might
see the similarities between this one
and that one this one is just this big
chain rather dude it's almost exactly
you can see the format okay
so let's give it a go I'll admit our
working should really mirror what's
going on here as well so here you got
your actual happening yeah so I'm gonna
write it
Vee you - yep
plus you now V - here is five on five X
minus one so that's where the cans leaks
gonna happen babies - 5 X just become
big ones 5 so now what you've got here
is having the problems with first line
yes
what kids that's okay you've got five
law 5x minus one cancel cancel cancel
cancel so therefore the statement that I
would fall you could form it a couple of
different ways if I just wanted to
interact that the integral of st. morg
5x minus one okay so I'm taking that 5s
so that means it's gonna be this with a
1/5 at the front so 5x by this one 5x
plus constant okay so can you see cuz I
divided this by five I divided this by
five and that's what I get
okay now let's see if we can generalize
think about where all the numbers came
from and how they affected what we had
to eat okay so if I were to say law golf
ax + hey where's the one-fifth come from
that was the coefficient of x wasn't it
right that's why I came out the front
because of chain okay so therefore here
I'll have one a gray instead whatever
now all of these things they're very
very simple the 5x minus 1 that is the
ax plus B that I've just introduced now
this minus 5x why did I have it there it
was here to cancel out this term so what
I needed to be is to match up with that
constant that I'll get up there which
comes from that coefficient which is
just Hey okay now like I said these are
kind of a bit more than awkward okay
which is why you'll get them as
differentiate heads integrate questions
they weren't telling this they were
saying they don't integrate that good
luck buddy you don't know actually
they'll give you that kind of clue
understandable now you can see the way
their divorce last what this is pretty
simple the derivative of log of X to the
power of seven okay this is simple chain
simple trick
let's do the outside first what do I do
it's something to the power of seven
power comes out the front and then the
power is usually by one okay we did the
outside that's do the inside down which
is whatever X so I just shut that on the
bottom
so what integral would reform off that
well again I'll write it without burn
for constant over here so if I were to
integrate log X all the power of six on
X with respect to X so what I've done is
I've divided by seven so the by this by
seven as well seven that should look
familiar shouldn't there right in fact
it's just like the rule for integrating
powers the crucial difference is there's
an X down there to compensate for the
fact you've got log X in there okay so
let's just quickly generalize if I were
to get two great log X to the power of n
correct okay well it's gonna happen it's
just like house isn't it
the power is gonna go up and then you'll
divide by the new power so when the
power goes up you'll get and +1 binding
to you by that